[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina
torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en marte donde el
explorador percibirnos logró recolectar
dos muestras de suelo tras el análisis
inicial la nasa explicó que provienen de
rocas probablemente de origen volcánico
y que contienen toques o pizcas de sales
que puedan retener burbujas de agua
antigua y que darían pistas de cómo se
formó esa área su historia de agua y si
alguna vez hubo vida pasada y este es un
gran lugar para explorar habitas
antiguos es un gran lugar para buscar
vida y como una ventaja adicional justo
fuera del borde del cráter ya cero se
encuentran algunas de las rocas más
antiguos y mejor expuestas en marte de
un periodo de tiempo incluso mil
millones de años antes se prevé que el
perseverante continúe recolectando
muestras de roca y del suelo y las
deposite en tubos del tamaño de lápices
posteriormente si todo sale según lo
planeado en 2028 un rover de la agencia
espacial europea aterrizará en marte
recogerá las muestras y las traerá de
vuelta a nuestro planeta
llegarían en 2031
este es un gran paso en lo que la
comunidad científica ha querido durante
más de 50 años que es traer muestras del
planeta rojo el primer intento fue una
excepción pero marte siempre te
sorprende
si cambiamos de tema vamos ahora hasta
egipto hace 43 millones de años una
especie particular de ballena cuadrúpeda
existió en la tierra esto es lo que
aseguran científicos egipcios que
explican que esta fue una especie
semiacuática que vivía en la tierra pero
cazaba en el agua
la ballena acción viste tú sandwich
vivió hace 43 millones de años en la
depresión de fayum su longitud era de
aproximadamente 3 metros y pesaba
alrededor de 600 kilogramos por lo tanto
es uno de los depredadores más grandes y
feroces de la región
los datos disponibles hasta ahora
exponen que la transición de las
ballenas hasta convertirse en animales
exclusivamente acuáticos duró unos 10
millones de años y el fósil arroja luz
sobre ese proceso pues la especie
estaría en la mitad de la cadena
evolutiva
continuamos ahora en corea del sur
porque un grupo de científicos creó un
material que se asemeja a la piel de un
camaleón por lo que puede camuflarse de
acuerdo con los colores que haya
alrededor y
está hecho con capas de cristal líquido
termocrómicos que pueden cambiar de
color con la temperatura y debajo hay
una capa de calentadores de nanocables
de plata que pueden ajustar la
temperatura las dos capas se colocan
sobre un sustrato de plástico el espesor
total de esas tres capas es de sólo
decenas de micrómetros por lo que se
puede doblar fácilmente su micromundo
cuña del ítem de las responsables
aseguran que este tipo de material
podría usarse en uniformes militares
para ayudarle a soldados a mimetizarse
con el entorno además podría emplearse
en moda o en exteriores de vehículos y
edificios como parte de una tecnología
de proyección
la información sobre el color que
detectan los sensores se envía a un
microprocesador el micro pro el
microprocesador tiene información sobre
la temperatura necesaria para generar
ciertos colores entonces le ordena a los
calentadores que produzcan cierta
temperatura y crea una tonalidad basada
en ello johan seguido de pares dónde
nunca york está vestida y en otros temas
tecnológicos vamos a conocer un poco más
del más reciente iphone anunciado por
apple
su nombre será iphone 13 y vendrá en
cuatro versiones la mini la estándar la
pro y la promax los modelos mantienen el
diseño de la versión 12 presentada el
año pasado sin embargo éstos usan un
chip más avanzado el lifting bayón ica
exclusivo de apple que mejora el
rendimiento y hay un aumento en la
duración de la batería además una de las
características más destacadas es el
modo cinemático para vídeos que permite
que el usuario cambia el foco de la
cámara de un punto al otro cuando se
encuentra grabando imágenes
por su parte del 13 pruebes el primer
modelo en la historia del iphone que
llega a tener un almacenamiento de un
terabyte ipod/iphone sorting free match
me pareció que el iphone 13 era más o
menos lo que todos esperaban fue una
mejora importante en el rendimiento del
chip a 15
mejora sustancial en las capacidades de
la cámara y una mejora importante en la
duración de la batería todas las cosas
básicas que estás buscando pero no fue
dramático ya sabes uso la analogía de
que a paul es como una banda de pop que
saca álbumes todos los años y algunos
álbumes son grandes éxitos y otros
álbumes son simplemente está bien pero
sus fans los aman todos y
finalizamos en italia porque para
conmemorar los 700 años desde la muerte
del poeta dante alighieri se está
realizando una exposición en 3-d de su
más famosa obra la divina comedia la
muestra es proyectada en la basílica de
la santa cruz en florencia la proyección
contiene escenas tomadas del infierno el
purgatorio y el paraíso y la idea de los
responsables es llevar a los visitantes
por el viaje ficticio que el poeta
utilizó para exponer sus puntos de vista
sobre religión moralidad política y
sociedad
así llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía y
continúen con más en france24 france24
puntocom
[Música]